it was on board This Plane the uranium
arrived in Britain a passenger jet
operated by Oman Air that landed at
Heathrow just after Christmas among the
suitcases on board a shipment of scrap
metal contaminated with a radioactive
substance that can be used to make
nuclear weapons
the protections at the airport
functioned as they should have done
there is extensive screening at ports
and airports in this country to keep the
public safe and it worked
the amount of material we're talking
about was very small and there was no
threat to Public Health or Public Safety
identified the package originated in
Pakistan it was first flown to Muscat in
Oman before being transferred onto
another flight to the UK it arrived at
Heathrow just after 6 pm and was
detected during routine screening
because it was emitting radiation
waterfall staff were on strike here the
day the uranium arrived which meant many
cargo officials were actually redeployed
to passport duties but it brought a
force Source has told Sky News that the
one Department that wasn't scaled back
was the security screening team and it
was for this very purpose
but it is a concern the material was
able to get this far through airports
and across continents Undeclared it
absolutely shouldn't be on a commercial
airliner we can use move nuclear
material like uranium and plutonium
around the world it's usually done in
caskets heavily protected
um occasionally by air but not on
commercial airliners who the material
was for is not known nor its intended
use the contamination perhaps the result
of poor handling or was it something
more Sinister a sign London is being
used as a toxic trading Hub what it may
mean is if London is being used to trade
and prove sampling capability of what
can be sold this is very serious and if
so it's an indicator of part of the
weapons build up we're seeing
so far no arrests have been made but
counter-terror police say they'll follow
every Avenue to establish how this
happened an Undeclared arrival that
could have been deadly either Bennett
Sky News